they're disgusted by him they look at
their arms as if they've been
contaminated because he may have touched
them hey guys I'm off the grid for
August but that does not stop leftist
lunatics for coming for your children
calling you racist and trying to take
all your money enjoy so this video is
circulating social media right now two
men carrying out a social experiment
where they're both walking down the
street one is white one is black they're
both blind and they're reaching out
physically to strangers for help
as you can watch and see every single
person helps the white man zero percent
help the black man or not only do they
not help him they are rejecting him
they're pulling away from him they're
disgusted by him they look at their arms
as if they've been contaminated because
he may have touched them
as sad as it is this video does a great
job of highlighting the importance of
intersectionality
they both have the same disability
they're reaching out for help in the
same way but because one is both black
and disabled he is perceived very
differently than the white man
now I want you to think about this on a
larger scale about how this disgust
could manifest in healthcare settings in
education settings in police
interactions Etc
this is why it's so important to
consider all aspects of who someone is
every disabled person does not
experience the same life
when you're both black and disabled your
oppression is compounded by race
this is why I hate and I never answer
and don't understand the question why
does everything have to be about race
because it literally is our livelihood
has to do with our race and it's not by
our choice